Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
January six 2014
wow.
Can you believe we're already 14 years into this century.
Can you believe that you're going to die this century unless they come up with
some Rogaine for you?
Fucking hot.
Yes you are.
You are going to die.
Let's try to call it right now.
I was born in the year of our Lord 1968 so my goal in life is I'd like to see
the 70s again.
All right.
Cause the first time was just so groovy man.
Sorry I'm fucking punched drunk.
Uh,
getting back.
Anyways,
stay focused this week bill.
Stay fucking focused.
Um,
yeah,
I'd like to make it to about 2072 I'll be 104 years old.
You know,
it'll be right before the fair.
Dead Getting Ready.
They're getting geared up for another fucking bicentennial.
Tricentennial is that what it's going to be?
The tricentennial everybody and they'll come wheeling me out.
He's so old.
He remembers this second one,
the bicentennial and I'd be like,
wow.
Right.
Salad brains.
There was a hundred years ago today that Richard Nixon resigned from office,
or I get to watch that ship,
the hundredth anniversary of the assassination of a fucking John F.
Kennedy Guy.
Suddenly dumber fucking and uh,
what else would I see?
The hundredth anniversary of,
of uh,
the Philadelphia Eagles win in a fucking championship.
You assholes.
I have held is you lose yesterday.
I like to sinks.
I like when they go march and then,
but you know,
something Versie got me all hyped up that like the eagles were probably the best
match up for the Seahawks.
And to me,
I think the Seahawks are going to win the whole thing,
but there would be nothing funnier if they didn't.
I got money on him to win it,
but it would just be fucking hilarious if they didn't.
And then their fans had to go home to 12 men,
12 minute.
They have to go fucking home again with that little fucking piece of paper on
the wall for their world record.
The loudest crowd ever.
Really?
You don't think the Arab spring was a little louder?
You don't think that that crowd was a little bit louder.
We're running for their lives,
um,
after being dispersed anyways.
What the fuck am I talking about here?
Um,
you know,
I'm really getting tired of people who don't live in the United States of
America talking about it and then going,
you know,
and did it.
This is happening and this is happening and I just feel like people aren't even
aware of it.
You stupid,
arrogant fucking consequent of what a fuck do you get off thinking you know more
about my country then I fucking live here.
Why do I tell somebody in Greece what the fight?
Don't think anybody in Greece realized what's going on in their country.
Listen,
fuck.
Heads from around the world.
World,
world,
world.
We know what's going on here.
What would you have us do?
Protestors in this country are treated the exact same fucking way they are
around the world.
If you're lucky,
all you get is the water cannon.
If you lucky,
only for a year,
die from the rubber bullets.
Okay?
All right.
That's what happens.
All right,
Mister fucking big mouths out there.
All right.
You want to start the fucking revolution?
I'll,
I'll join it.
You started,
you get on point.
All right there.
Gandy,
you fucking take the sheet off your goddamn bed.
Put on your fucking sandals and you walk down the street.
I'll be right behind you in the masses.
It's just,
and I don't think they were aware of it.
Ah,
with one more fucking douchebag.
Oh,
really?
Is it really corrupt?
Like you're fucking country also.
Rarely are we starting wars because of x,
Y and Z.
Always that why were over there?
I couldn't figure it out.
I thought we were over there making a fucking dairy queen.
Thank you for explaining it to me.
Person from somewhere else.
Yeah.
With your fucking perspective from Nova Scotia.
Speaking of Nova Scotia.
Oh,
freckles is going to come to town.
No.
What just happened to my computer?
Oh,
freckles is coming to town.
I just got my dates,
um,
for the big Canadian tour for the big ass fucking Canadian tour.
Um,
I can tell you this,
I can't tell you when it starts on March 1st and here's some of the,
the,
the wonderful Canadian cities that I'm going to be heading,
provinces,
whatever the fuck you want to call them.
I'm going to be going there and then you guys can tell me what's wrong with my
country and then say to my face that you're surprised that I'm not aware of it.
You don't like,
you don't think I have the Internet.
All right.
Uh,
capital.
I'll be at the Capitol theater and a New Brunswick and mock cocked mos.
N C t.
O n New Brunswick.
That one starts,
that's March 1st.
March 2nd.
I'll be at the Rebecca Kahn Auditorium in Halifax,
Nova Scotia.
On the 5th of March I'll be in Montreal,
Quebec.
Okay.
Um,
the sixth,
there'll be an Ottawa seventh I'll be in Hamilton,
Ontario.
The eighth.
I'll be in Toronto,
Ontario
on the 13th.
I'm going to be in Winnipeg on the 14th.
I'm going to be in Edmonton on the 15th.
I'm going to be in Calgary.
Gow Go Rawr care.
Laura Gallo,
re Calgary.
Um,
and then I'm going to be in the 60s.
I'm going to finish it up on the west coast in Vancouver,
British Columbia.
So there you go.
All right.
And I'm going to go up there and ask you guys if you're,
if you're aware of what's going on in your country.
Um,
I'm sorry.
I know,
uh,
I know I've,
I know I've been doing a lot of yelling on this podcast and I,
I apologize.
I apologize for my mood.
I apologize too.
Um,
oh,
I don't even fucking know.
Isn't that what you have to do now as a comedian?
You make a fucking joke and then you have to go out and apologize.
Every God damn week,
somebody said something,
somebody decides to take it seriously,
then all of a sudden the person has to apologize.
You know,
like they meant it.
Oh,
you took it seriously.
So I guess now I meant it once.
You're like,
no,
why doesn't everybody just collectively grow a tougher skin?
Why don't you do that?
What Bell?
Why did you stop being such a cunt?
Well,
hey,
that's a decent point.
That's a decent point.
Um,
somebody asked was talking to me about fat shaming this week once again,
talking about how it's a terrible thing to do.
I got to tell you something.
If you guys want,
I love fat shaming.
I absolutely love it.
That's how I stay in shape.
Okay?
I fat shame myself.
Damn.
I get out of shape.
I just stand in the mirror luggage.
You look what you did.
You fucking God damn pink pig.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
And I just trashed myself.
I just yell at myself.
It's,
it's the weirdest thing to yell at yourself in the mirror because you getting in
your grill and you're looking away at the same time.
It's fucking tremendous.
It's like that movie face off,
except it's,
it's all you,
right?
Isn't that what happened in that movie?
Um,
anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
Uh,
I do one of these every sort of Monday.
I like putting them out late,
just watching people cause they take the fucking name.
So literally,
who'd you go to?
Where'd you go to you?
Tuesday?
I have to do a podcast.
Okay.
Yeah.
When you went to the movie theater to go see Saturday night fever on a Thursday.
What did you
Bidwell Asia call this Thursday night fever cause it takes Thursday.
You can listen to them whenever you want to.
I have years of these fucking things years and years.
Lawrence,
I have recorded,
go listen to a back one.
First of all.
It's fucking Monday.
Shouldn't you be at work?
You asshole.
Oh,
I'm on my soapbox this week.
Um,
anyways,
so I was flying back from Pittsburgh this weekend and uh,
I had basically the greatest weekend of my life.
Um,
this is,
why do I even start this fucking way?
I guess I've got to start at the beginning of the week,
right?
What do I work my way backwards?
Where do you,
what do you guys want to hear?
You want to hear this shit show into the greatest fucking weekend in my life
where you want to hear about the greatest weekend of my life and then I'll
backtrack into the shit show.
Would that make you feel better?
I think it would judge him by the tone on the Internet that,
Oh wow,
bill had a great fucking time.
I should lead with that and then go back to my,
and I should end with my embarrassments.
All right,
so it lands softly and you can feel okay at your plastic fucking desk that they
got it.
Office Max.
All right?
That's when you know you're not making it in life when your desk is made out of
plastic,
all right?
Nobody ever sat behind a plastic desk chomping on a nice cigar after making some
fucking zillion dollar deal that caused one arm diamond diggers to be a little
further down in the mud.
Nobody's ever done that,
okay?
You want a fucking wood desk desks?
We had a wood case.
I confused you.
All right?
And if you're sitting in a plastic desks right now,
I'm not saying you're a bad person,
but I'm saying that you need to now desk shame yourself,
right?
Once you take out your little compact or maybe look into your little Zippo
lighter,
look into your eyes and I want you to find the sadness.
I want you to look a little deeper and I want you to see the dream way in the
back of your eyes and I want to know where it went and when you're going to
bring it back up to the fucking front row.
All right?
Now that might've sound country,
but that was supposed to inspire you.
So right now I want you to slam your fist down on your plastic desk until it
fucking shed is.
And I don't know what else the rest of the planets,
maybe you can get everybody else to start doing it like a bunch of monkeys.
You just start doing it and start throwing your shit around the room.
I Dunno what tip over your cubicles.
I want that for.
Alia isn't as fun to scare people in suits.
So you know some Joe Rosen never picks up his phone and now he's calling me a
Joey roses.
I'm doing my podcast.
And unlike you,
I actually pick up my phone.
You fucking pencil shaped cunt.
Hey,
let me call you after this.
this is a great time,
Joe.
Now that we're both living on the same coast to maybe,
oh,
uh,
let the listeners know that,
that there's a lot of rumors that uh,
that the,
the uh,
uninformed,
show my come back together again.
Yeah.
Landon and McCarthy.
Mike finally bury the hatchet.
Right.
Help.
You guys can hear that.
All right.
Fuck it.
I'll call you later,
right?
All right Joe.
Um,
anyways,
fuck head.
Geez.
Did I pull that out of fourth grade recess?
Hey Dick face.
Um,
anyways,
I don't know where to start.
All right,
fuck it.
I'm going to go with the most vivid memory this weekend.
I had the greatest weekend in my life,
uh,
about,
I don't know how many months ago.
The wonderful,
the generous,
the always classy and sometimes sassy Randy Bauman from wd VIII in Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania.
Um,
who,
who basically he helped build me in that market.
You know,
I wasn't selling shit.
I wasn't selling any tickets in Pittsburgh.
And um,
I think Billy guard Dell told me about him.
I can't remember how the hell the thing went down,
but he has got this great morning radio show and he said,
listen,
next time you come to Pittsburgh,
come in,
fly in on a Monday night,
I'll have you on the radio Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday you run your freckled face for the four days and we'll,
we'll,
we'll get you going in this market.
He helped build me up and all that type of stays.
If that wasn't enough.
So he turned that weak market into one of my strongest cities to go to.
And it is such a great city to go to is if that wasn't enough,
all Randy Baume and called me up,
I don't know how many months ago.
And he says,
listen,
would you be interested in doing stand up at the,
uh,
you know,
Mario Lemieux has a,
a,
a fantasy camp and it raises money for cancer research and all this type of
stuff.
It's just this great thing.
He come in,
you do stand up,
you meet some of the guys.
He always has some of the guys he played with their hanging out,
blah,
blah.
And I was just like,
yeah.
It was like,
absolutely.
That's all it started.
This was just this little thing.
And then he calls me back,
he goes,
Hey,
don't you play hockey a little bit?
I'm like,
yeah,
you know,
I try,
I try.
He goes away.
They have a,
you know the camp that,
you know,
the,
everybody plays hockey.
They have like four teams,
they play each other and all that type of stuff.
If you want to come on and play with one of the teams one day you play with the
penguins play and all that,
would you like to do that?
I'm like,
absolutely.
Of course I would.
So long story short,
I show up and uh,
I bring my pads and I bring all this stuff cause I think,
I just think it's just going to be a pickup game,
a hockey and um,
I don't know,
without getting like tacky and just say,
and
yeah,
all the stuff that they gave everybody who it's,
it's ridiculous.
You show up,
they give you a frigging hockey bag with you,
God damn name on it.
And inside there is all,
all the,
all the stuff,
the socks,
the gloves,
the jersey,
a helmet,
the whole thing.
Then all you have to do is just bring your pads,
you're good in a stick and you find,
and next thing you know
you're,
you're playing hockey weight with the penguins play.
Oh and you also go to the hockey game.
If it was I,
it's too much to even try to describe.
So anyways,
we do the standup show.
I don't know who's in the crowd other than Mario Lemieux and I don't want to
know,
I don't want to fucking know who's there because,
because they are legends.
And of course I go on stage.
I looked to the right and is Mario Lemieux sitting there?
It's like he can hide when you're six foot six and uh,
thank God I saw him smiling and he was laughing.
Long story short at the end,
at the end of it I met like seven or eight guys that I grew up watching.
I Dunno.
It was just,
it was the sickest thing ever.
I Dunno.
It was unbelievable.
Paul coffee,
you know,
other than Bobby,
your the greatest frigging defense men of all time.
Theo Fleury,
Brian,
Traci,
Aa.
It was,
it was insane.
It was fucking insane.
The whole tie Domi
that they were all in the crowd.
Thank God I didn't know.
Thank God I didn't know Jesus Christ.
It was my head's spinning right now.
And,
and we end up going out.
We're playing on the ice.
Traci as our coach Lemieux's on the other team with Paul Coffee.
Mark recky was on my team two years removed from winning a Stanley Cup on play
with this guy.
And I was,
it was insane.
And then a bunch of regular people,
actually,
everybody else was better than I was.
But I mean,
just were all skating with them.
It was insane.
It was fucking insane.
I'm speechless.
I,
I don't,
you know,
I don't even have the only funny story I can think of for the weekend cause I
was in a daze the whole weekend.
It was so awesome.
Was,
uh,
how awful I played
at Jesus Christ.
Fucking brutal.
Um,
I really wanted to play a lot better than I did.
I'm not gonna lie to you and everyone's doing it,
then,
hey,
you know,
you were good for three years and you were good.
I don't sugarcoat it.
I sucked.
So I'm motivated to,
um,
I'm motivated to fucking,
uh,
to get better at that game.
So if I ever get to do a play again,
I can actually maybe the puck from wasn't two seconds without getting taken away
from me,
but,
uh,
it was just the best,
the best fucking time I ever had.
And uh,
I still can't believe it happened.
I was actually sitting there and Steve Byrne was the other con comic on it.
I'm sitting on the bench and he's playing defense with Paul Coffee and I'm
watching Paul Coffee Pass the puck to my buddy was the sickest thing was the
sickest fucking thing I've ever seen in my life.
Um,
yeah,
so that happened.
And uh,
so that was the great,
okay.
So that was the great thing this weekend to tie domi showed us how he,
how he would beat up a guy a foot taller.
He showed us his technique.
I'm not going to get into it.
Ask him about it someday if you ever run into him.
It was fucking unbelievable.
And they were all hilarious.
They were all great guys.
Um,
who else ready?
Hilliard played for the Bruins for awhile.
Early on when I first started watching the Bruins.
It was,
it was,
it was insane.
It was absolutely insane.
Um,
I'm trying,
I'm trying to make sure I don't forget anybody.
Rick talking.
Jesus Christ.
He was skating by
Eddie Johnston,
the Bruins goalie who will one,
it's 70 and 72 and I was going to us like star struck on,
I just read Bobby always book turn to like an eight year old kid and he goes,
I talked to on this morning,
I'll tell him you liked it.
And I was like,
Oh,
you are.
It was just,
it was insane.
The greatest thing ever,
if you're ever gonna do a fantasy camp,
there's no way.
There's one out there that's better than the Mario Lemieux one.
I got to tell you,
they,
it was 100% first class.
It was just the greatest thing ever.
All right.
So that's that.
All right now
and right now I know I'm going to get an up punch of tweets going,
Bill,
fuck you go fuck yourself for having that experience.
And you know what?
You're right.
I have no business having an experience like that.
Thank you to Randy Bauman for hooking the whole God damn thing up.
Um,
all right,
plowing ahead here.
Uh,
what do I got here?
But let's do some advertising.
Do some advertising,
how much you read some Avatar,
how about you make an attempt bill.
Alright,
Hulu plus.
Okay,
here we go.
Hulu plus you've probably tried hulu.com now with Hulu plus you can watch your
favorite shows anytime,
any way.
Hulu plus let you watch thousands of hit TV shows and a selection of Gulf of a
claimed movies on your television or on the go with your smart phone or tablet.
And it all streams in HD for the best viewing experience with Hulu.
Plus you can watch your favorite current shows like Saturday night live
community and family guy.
You can also check out exclusive content including Hulu originals like the
awesome starring SNLs Seth Meyers and Moon Boys' starring Chris O'Dowd from
bridesmaids.
Hulu plus also offers a great selection of a claim films for only seven 99 a
month.
You can stream as many TV shows and movies as you want wherever you want right
now.
You can try Hulu plus for free for two weeks when you go to Hulu plus.com/bill
that's a special offer for my listeners.
Make sure you use Hulu plus.com/bill so you get the extended free trial and that
they know that I sent you over there.
Go to Hulu plus.com/bill now or click the Hulu plus banner on the podcast page
at [inaudible] dot com hey,
that wasn't bad.
I only screwed up once I was one over all right.
Dollar Shave Club for a couple of bucks a month.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing quality razors right to your door.
Not only does it save you a ton of cash,
it saves you from trudging your sorry ass to the drug store for a pack of
blades.
Personally,
I always get stuck behind the drug addict who's going there to buy some sort of
something that he could stick into his arms and some grapefruit juice.
I don't know about you and it's a pain in the ass,
but now with dollar shave club for just a couple bucks a month,
you don't have to deal with that anymore.
Why?
Because amazing quality raises will be delivered right to your door.
That's right.
No more wasting time and no more getting hit up for 20 bucks.
Every time you buy a razor,
it's highway robbery.
Everybody here meaning me is getting that dollar shave club blades and you
should do it too and is a genius idea.
While you're at it,
try replacing your old shaving cream with doctor Cav is Evie shave butter from
dollar shave club.com trust me,
your face will thank you later.
Don't waste time at the drug store behind the lady paying and Penny's.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash [inaudible] go to [inaudible] dot com
and click on the dollar shave club banner.
Keep your stress level low when your bank account Balance High Shave time,
shave money.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash burr and finally for the hat trick,
legal zoom.
You know people,
some things like starting a business or protecting your family with a will
aren't like you're ah God.
This first sentence of this copy,
it just kills me.
All right,
Bill burr tries not to fuck it up.
Take to dupe to legal zoom.com some things like starting a business or
protecting your family with the will aren't like your other new year's
resolutions.
You can't afford to blow them off.
Instead of less snacking and more exercise,
put them at the top of your list.
What instead of less snacking and more excess exercise,
What the stuff I just read?
Yeah,
Jesus.
I'm confused.
Let's start over again.
Legal zoom.com everybody.
Some things like starting a business or protecting your family with the will
aren't like your other new year's resolutions.
You can't afford to blow him off.
Instead of less snacking and more exercise,
put them at the top of your list.
Legal Zoom helps you incorporate or form an LLC with their simple questionnaire.
Starting at $99 over 1 million entrepreneurs had done it and 90% of customers
recommend legal zoom to friends and family.
You can also create a will starting at just 69 bucks or even a living trust
quickly and easily get peace of mind and protection.
No surprise fees,
no hassles,
man,
no headaches.
Legal Zoom step by step process was created by a team of experts in law and
technology.
Legal Zoom,
however,
is not a law firm but you,
but they can connect you with the third party attorney and provide you with any
help,
self help services that you need from wills to business formations,
trademarks,
powers of attorney and more.
Go to legal zoom.com for even more savings.
Type in bur bur into the referral box at checkout.
Don't put off things that you need to do today.
Go to legal zoom.com now and use a diff,
the discount code burpee.
You are our,
that's legalzoom.com.
Discount Code Burn,
B U R R Jesus Christ.
Fucking butcher.
Um,
all right,
so backing up a little bit earlier this week,
um,
I did the new years eve Gig at the Wiltern theater and um,
right here in Los Angeles and a that's a theater that I've been wanting to do
for years.
It's just a art deco building.
It's just awesome.
I've seen a bunch of great rock shows there.
So,
uh,
them crooked vultures.
I saw when the last shows of velvet revolver.
Um,
I just saw a bunch of great things there.
I saw a cup,
I saw modern drummer drum off there.
What else?
I know I've seen like 10 shows there.
I can't really think of anything else.
Maybe some of them were like Nia shows,
who knows?
Anyways,
so I finally got to go down.
I went down there went,
oh,
I know,
I went down there when Rogan is Stan hope we're down there knocking it out of
the park.
We had the Greg Geraldo benefit down there was just one that I always wanted to,
to uh,
to headlines Someday and I got to do it.
And I did it with Andrew families.
Jason lie hadn't Joe Bart,
nick and it was just,
it was just such an awesome night.
Fucking great crowd.
Everybody seemed to have a great time.
And um,
all my friends had great sets in Barton.
Nick went on in front of me and was in rare phone was in rare form.
He,
he,
he brought the fucking lumber that night.
Um,
it was just an unreal night and then we had a DJ come out in the end.
I got to do the countdown,
took some pictures with some fans afterwards.
It was just a great way to start the new year.
So,
uh,
the next day,
um,
actually later on that day cause we'd left one,
two o'clock in the morning,
we went over to the Rose Bowl and uh,
I was an absolute shit show this year.
I am embarrassed at myself.
I drank so much.
Usually I pass out during the game for like five minutes and somebody nudges me
and I wake up,
I drank so much,
I fucking passed out at the tailgate
fucking,
I don't know what happened.
I started hitting the hard stuff.
I shotgun a beer all right.
For the first time in my life,
by the way,
I never did it.
I never did it cause I was too afraid.
There was always girls around.
I was like,
I'm going to do it and it's going to go all over me and then nobody's going to
like me and I'm going to have to switch schools because that's the way my brain
would work rather than maybe they'd laugh and he'd say something funny and next
thing you know you're having a good time with one of low
that's not on my brain.
Looked,
it goes,
smashed me over there with the beer can throw me off a fucking cliff.
Like that's how my fucking,
that's how my brain still works.
But I am aware of it now and as it starts screaming and wine and I just,
there's another voice in my head going now.
It's not,
it's a night.
It's not going to happen.
It's going to be fine.
The light's going to turn green and you're going to get down the road.
There's going to be something to eat.
You'll be fine.
Um,
fucking Jason Law head smoked a pork shoulder
and uh,
I have no recollection of eating it.
Okay.
I don't even remember it.
I was,
I blacked out.
Eight a pork shoulder sandwich and then I passed out somewhere in there.
I shotgun to beer and then walking in
to the fucking Roseville,
I started screaming at this girl was like 23 and cowboy boots screaming,
you're not as hot as you think you are to the point it got uncomfortable.
It's just fucking,
I vaguely remember that.
Vaguely remember that.
And they reminded me afterwards and I have been
so fucking embarrassed,
so fucking embarrassed this whole,
I just,
you know,
like when you do something horrible like that,
I don't know about you guys,
but when I think about it,
I like in my head,
I just start talking out loud,
making noises to kind of drown out the thought.
I would just think about,
I'd be like,
ah,
Jesus is just,
and I would do it like standing in line at security at an airport and people
looking at me like,
now I'm like a fucking terrorist.
And it's like,
no,
no.
I was a scary drunk older man.
To what,
2124 year old woman.
It was just awful.
So as always,
I uh,
I am on the wagon again.
I was on the wagon until the fucking hockey thing this weekend.
Okay.
It's not like,
you know,
okay.
When guys you grew up,
grew up watching,
start buying beers and shit,
you're going to be like Clark fucking Gillies.
Sorry.
I met Clark Gillies last night,
talk to him about his fist fights with Dave Schultz.
I got to do that.
Did I get to do it?
Is it all a fucking dream?
I don't even remember.
So anyway,
so I am on the wagon,
but I took two days off.
So,
um,
it was insane.
And I had like fucking three of those sandwiches,
you know where they have the French fries in the Coleslaw and I'm on the fucking
bread week.
We closed down that place one night.
Me,
Steve Byrne and fucking bomb and a couple other,
a couple other people.
I just close that place down.
Fucking burn was an animal man.
Every time we went we went to the penguins game,
he ordered two of them and then we went to the fucking place.
Like the next day after our show,
I should really know the name of the place.
It's like famous.
I never remember the names of the restaurants.
He fucking,
he ate two more.
He ordered two when I eat half of his,
a Pastrami,
one with French fries and fucking Cole slaw.
It was insane.
And then last night they had catering and it was more of him and he just kept,
he can't not eat them.
They're delicious.
They make you obese,
they're awesome.
They're Pittsburgh.
It's everything.
Pittsburgh,
if he could make Pittsburgh and do a fucking sandwich,
this is the God damn sandwich.
Some of the best heart attack food you'll ever have.
I would actually say that Pittsburgh rivals,
Chicago,
phenomenal,
phenomenal fucking heart attack food.
Just like,
okay,
just that,
that city is just all,
you know,
it starts tomorrow,
the Diet starts tomorrow.
I'm quitting drinking tomorrow.
Like,
like the,
I,
if I lived in Chicago or if I lived in Pittsburgh,
I would be about 260 pounds,
you know,
and at that point you have to grow a mustache,
some sort of facial hair.
Do you know?
Okay
to to,
to just hide your big fucking face.
What a fucking weekend man.
Now all this shit's coming back to me.
Traci told the story of how he scored the fastest goal ever.
I actually watched it on youtube when I was looking up his highlights when I was
going to go there to do the show and I knew that he was going to be there and
next thing you know,
he was talking about it and was standing in on a phone watching it.
He scored in five seconds and he's just graciously standing there like he hasn't
won six Stanley cups talking to meet.
Like I like I'm fucking remotely on his level.
Greatest fucking guys ever this weekend.
He's telling me breaking down the whole play
of how we scored in five seconds and how it's only been tied.
He did it against the Bruins then it was just a what?
A what?
A fucking weekend man.
Ah,
Christ.
I'm floating here.
Um,
so anyways,
okay.
Despite all of that.
You know,
it was funny as I was eating those French fries,
Cole slaw,
fucking,
I almost said tuberculosis sandwiches,
um,
meat sandwiches and the whole weekend though,
I was also doing yoga every day because I was not going to have my back give out
on me while I was out on the ice because I already knew what my performance
level was going to be like.
So I kind of like offset it a little bit.
But uh,
I'm looking pretty doe in these days,
not liking myself whatsoever.
Um,
so anyways,
that,
that was basically my weekend and then the rose bowl was an absolute,
it was awesome and I'm so pissed at myself that I got that fucking drunk.
Okay.
And that was belligerent.
And then also that,
I forget some of the best part in the tailgate flew by and then I have to wait a
whole nother year.
Next year I'm drinking fucking,
I'm drinking Miller.
That's it.
Champagne of beer.
I'm doing that.
They go down nice and easy at fucking seven in the morning.
Kick a couple of those back when I have an Omelet,
throw the football around.
Fucking tailgate like you've been there before,
Bill.
You know,
I'm like at these fucking Rosebowl tailgates.
I'm like Charlie Brown every fucking year trying to kick the football and Lucy
pulls it away.
How many fucking years bill?
One of them.
I was stone sober.
You know what's funny?
I don't even remember that one either.
Um,
anyways,
but as always,
Jason,
law head Rosebowl tailgate legend,
if you ever are around that man,
when he's near a fucking grill,
grab yourself a paper plate in.
Wait,
you fucking turned just that dude.
He just keeps getting better at cooking.
It's fucking insane.
I remember at one point some woman walked by and she looked at the fucking,
the uh,
the pork shoulder that he was,
he was smoking and she said,
oh,
that's nice.
Okay.
Can I swear to God if I had a couple more beers I would have tackled her.
That's a nice fucking kind of understatement is that I vaguely remember talking
into a camera shit face going.
Did you grow up in a city of gold?
You know,
it's fucking Nice.
Jesus Christ.
I'm sure your mom was swell.
Um,
alright,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
what else did I want to talk about?
I didn't even have a chance to watch any of the football.
Um,
and I apologize what I said about the eagles.
I'm not trying to rub your face and it,
did anybody see the video with that guy,
that Eagle fan spitting that saints fans face?
Um,
I don't condone that behavior,
but you're a fucking asshole.
The other guy was a fucking asshole jumping up.
But you don't do that there.
There's,
there's an etiquette when you go into another stadium,
when you,
okay,
you want to show up wearing your,
your,
your fucking colors.
All right?
You know everybody's going to break your balls.
You'd go in,
you fucking roll with it.
You laugh,
you take the shit and then you show that you're not going to be an asshole.
And usually that works other than like in Oakland,
San Francisco,
San Diego of Philly for some reason,
I dunno out here that you get stabbed or shot or just it just,
it gets really ugly.
Um,
and in Philly,
you know,
I guess it gets ugly too,
but it's not like there hasn't been a bunch of stories about it.
Their team just lost in the playoffs and people are like,
well he doesn't have a right to chair.
He isn't sharing.
He's turning around Filming Sad Eagle Fans walking out of the stadium,
screaming who day,
who they are and all this type of shit.
And I guess the dude,
right?
Listen to it at the airport,
it was really loud,
I guess he said,
I'm going to spit in your face.
And he kept doing it and this dude just fucking effortlessly,
you know,
fluidly as he was exiting the stadium spit,
right.
This guy's face and a,
which is a terrible fucking thing to do.
Okay.
You shouldn't do it,
but it's one of those,
that guy literally should just go to central park.
It's three in the morning dress like Liberace,
jumping up and down,
holding a Satchel of money.
Go and look at all the money I got right.
And then when he gets hit over the head and,
and mugged,
alright,
that,
that's still wrong.
It shouldn't happen.
But what?
What are you doing?
Okay?
Why don't you tie a big fat steak?
Do Your fucking stomach and bloody steak and go jump in an alligator infested
fucking lake.
Why don't you do that?
And then it's supposed to feel bad for you when the alligator fucking eat you.
All right?
Uh,
that Eagle Fan was wrong.
He shouldn't have done that shit.
But the saints fan was,
was reckless with his own wellbeing.
Careless.
Sloppy.
All right.
If you were driving a fucking boat,
you would have run at a ground because you weren't paying attention.
You had no respect for yourself or your own safety or the dryness of your face
in that moment,
sir.
All right.
And he was not sharing.
He was taunting.
He was filming Eagle Fans leaving,
screaming that who day?
All right.
He's lucky he didn't get a bucket,
a urine dumped over his head.
You do that in Philly.
I'm surprised you lived.
So there you go.
So look up that video.
And like I said,
I don't condone that behavior obviously,
but I can't judge it considering I yelled at a,
a young lady,
young lady,
and cowboy boots because I was drunk.
So now I am back on the wagon.
All right.
Then I reserve the right that if I'm a,
you know,
okay.
If anything else like that happens,
I'm going to,
I'm going to start drinking again,
but I'm not,
I'm not,
you know,
like that fucking,
yeah.
You know,
I that
I give a fuck how long you were,
so,
but you would have started drinking too
anyways.
Uh,
what else in Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Oh my God.
I,
I would say if I ever see somebody with Kansas City Jersey on or something,
I just give him a hug,
but I wouldn't do that because that would actually make it worse.
That would be some sort of pandering,
uh,
what happened to Kansas City chiefs fan should not happen to anybody.
And I that includes Yankee fans.
Nobody should have to fucking go through that.
Uh,
but that is today's NFL with the rule changes.
You are never out of it.
That was absolutely fucking insane.
I feel bad for chief fence and uh,
I feel great for Andrew Luck because I liked that guy,
man.
I really think that that guy is a,
uh,
obviously,
I mean,
I'm not going out on live.
That guy is showing he's got that Elway thing.
He's got that fucking Elway thing.
He's got a cannon he can run.
He's never better than when the game's on the fucking line.
He showing hints of that and uh,
it's fucking scary.
The potential of that guy.
Um,
it's anywhere.
All these guys,
Cam Newton's having an unbelievable year.
Okay.
Um,
did they play this weekend?
I missed everything.
I was too busy fucking,
uh,
having the weekend of my life,
I still cannot fucking believe that happened.
I still cannot believe how nice all the players were,
how gracious all of them were.
They would just,
they will fucking hilarious.
Just standing around drinking beers,
breaking balls,
and then you went out and you played hockey with it was just,
it was fucking unbelievable.
Um,
unfucking believable.
I'll never get over it.
It's great.
It's fucking weekend of my life.
Um,
anyways,
so now yeah,
that's my thing.
I'm officially fucking oldest health 45 [inaudible] 46 this year,
so I'm doing the,
I'm hitting the yoga hard this year because I was starting to have like,
I like,
I'm so old,
I like throw out my back sleeping.
It's so fucking humbling.
You sit there and you lie to yourself,
you know,
I look good for my age.
I can still run around and shit and it just,
you just can't,
after a while I don't know what it is.
How do you throw your back out?
Sleeping.
Don't even fucking say it's the mattress.
I've been sleeping on this mattress.
It's a newer one.
I've been sleeping on it for a couple of years.
It's still got years left in it.
It's me.
Okay.
Oh Jesus Christ.
I wake up in the morning and my dog,
she does two stretches up dog down dog and she is shakes herself and she is
ready to go.
She gets a yawn in there somewhere else and she's ready to go.
And then she's staring at me and at this point,
yeah,
she knows not to get too excited because she knows the entire stretching routine
that I have to go through.
Just a walker down the street.
She gets excited.
Okay.
But then she just knows I have to,
I got to do like this whole,
like this six minutes stretch routine
and it drives,
it drives her nuts trying to fucking remain calm because she wants,
cause she loves going outside like every dog.
So God damn bed.
Um,
I dunno.
I guess I just,
I just have to,
uh,
I just have to accept it.
I end up,
oh,
I forgot to mention that during the new year's Gig,
we've got a bunch of emails.
People,
some people came in from New Mexico,
Phoenix,
Salt Lake City,
San Francisco,
Portland,
Sacramento,
Chicago,
San Diego,
New York City at Vancouver.
Man,
that's just,
that's fucking awesome.
Man.
I,
I've,
and I've got to tell you that that was a great show that night that really was a
great show.
I'm not even gonna lie.
I was,
uh,
I was on my game.
Everybody was on their game.
She came that night.
You definitely got a,
uh,
definitely get your money's worth.
And I'm actually thinking about maybe doing new year's in la every other year
because I,
you know,
I got the new hour going where it's supposed to be and it's worth the money
every other year as far as like,
uh,
if,
if I just did you fucking city,
you know what I mean?
If I come back a year later,
like half my ax still can be the same and I,
I fucked you over.
So I do it like every other year.
Um,
whatever,
I don't need to break down my fucking promise.
I don't want to you guys an explanation.
Do I?
I don't fucking know.
Anyways.
Uh,
where are we?
Where are we in the podcast here?
43 minutes flying by here.
All right,
let's get to,
uh,
oh,
here's an email right here.
Conveniently enough about the,
uh,
the Wiltern.
Uh,
Billy would,
I was at the Wiltern last night for your show.
My girlfriend and I drove,
drove down from Portland.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
take the five south the whole fucking way.
Uh,
we got tickets right when you announced it because we knew we wouldn't want to
do any of the traditional new year plans,
dinner and parties and all that bullshit.
They are all mediocre at best.
But last night's show was hilarious.
Thank you.
Everyone was hilarious.
Up and down,
the funniest show I've ever,
we stayed for the countdown and you didn't disappoint.
Oh,
it was great.
We had a DJ and I got to do the countdown and sing that depressing song.
It was fucking awesome.
Uh,
he said,
if ever the end of the world is coming,
I'd want you to do the final countdown before we all burst into oblivion.
Thanks again for the labs to come to Portland Christ.
It's been forever.
Yeah.
I haven't been there in a while.
Thank you.
That isn't even like a question or anything.
That was just a nice email and I appreciate it.
All right.
Australia.
Uh,
hi.
I was wondering if bill,
we'll return to Australia.
I have a group of friends who would appreciate seeing a standup show.
Thank you.
And kind regards.
Let's click out.
Nice emails are this week.
I think everybody made a new year's resolution to be a little nicer to me in the
emails.
You know,
maybe for once think about my feelings.
Ah,
yes.
I was talking to my agent today about,
uh,
putting together a run through a Australia and uh,
oh my fucking God.
Damn.
Phone never stops.
Um,
I'm definitely gonna do it.
I mean,
I'm hoping to tour the entire country.
If not,
I am at the very least.
I'm going to do a number of cities.
That is the game plan.
I'm hoping to go from Perth all the way across.
We'll see what it looks like.
You never know what I'm,
okay.
You know,
when you're going to cities,
you never been to,
you don't know if people are going to show up.
You gotta get a promoter who's going to believe in you.
You've got to get people going to hype the show,
Yada,
Yada.
But,
uh,
I really hope that,
we can put something together and maybe tack on New Zealand while I'm at it.
We shall see.
But it's nice to know that people are asking.
All right.
Long distance hiking.
The last week I mentioned that I went on a hike and we just kept going and going
like assholes,
not realizing that we had to walk back.
Hiking is not like a treadmill.
You don't just get to step off and be like,
oh,
I'm still,
despite the fact I walked for an hour,
I am still only,
you know,
10 paces from my phone,
the parking lot,
my car.
Um,
we ended up going on like an 11 mile hike and uh,
it was a exhausting to say the least.
So this person is writing about long distance hiking.
Another great old man thing to do yoga,
hockey,
ice hockey,
and a hiking.
Okay.
You know?
Um,
all right.
Hey Bill,
I've been listening to your podcasts long enough to know that you love hiking,
you hate getting fat and you get easily annoyed by day to day bullshit.
I really think you'd enjoy backpacking at Jesus
backpacking.
I know it's awesome,
but can you call it something else?
Backpacking.
I just feel like I'm fucking waiting for a bus,
picking my nose by ready to get the shit kicked out of me.
Hey,
you guys want to go backpacking to pack you put on your back and go backpacking
or long distance hiking.
Okay.
Let's call it that.
It's a really,
I don't have long distance hiking freaks me out because I figured at that point
you've walked long enough to run into something that can mall you to death slash
rip your face off or at the very least just sort of bite your throat until it
stops feeling the pulse,
you know,
start getting into that next weight class of animals.
I don't know.
You know,
mountain lions,
black bear,
grizzly bear,
fucking Anaconda,
whatever.
Exotic pet that somebody let loose that has no natural enemy that is now taking
over the forest.
Um,
long days or long distance hiking.
It's really,
it's really freeing to walk away from civilization for a week or more with the
solid pair of boots and everything you need strapped to your back.
Dude.
Fuck that.
You're more man or woman that I am.
I can't fucking deal with that.
I get scared.
I get,
I get freaked the fuck out.
I'd have to be out there with somebody who knew what they were doing,
who had a gun.
Uh,
automatic to not even semiautomatic.
I need something that I could spray and the general direction of the sound I
just heard and you know,
if we kill a couple of backpackers,
there's no one else around burying them as optional.
I would say leave them above ground cause they'll get picked away a lot quicker
than people will find their clothes.
I guess the bones would be there.
That's creepy.
See what happens when you go out in the wilderness.
You start fucking talking about shit like that.
I live in a suburb.
Okay.
There's plenty of people to shoot and I never think of donut.
They're right out there.
Right fucking out there.
And I never think of shooting them.
All of a sudden you get me backpacking or long distance hiking and I'm trying to
think out of bury bodies.
All right.
Every time I finish a long hike I come back looking healthier and leaner and
feeling refreshed.
Yeah.
Cause you were out there eating berries,
wiping your ass with fucking pine cones.
That's it.
That's why you have that peculiar look on your face.
Um,
no matter how much you eat on the trail,
you're guaranteed to lose weight.
If you spend six hours a day hiking with the 35 pound backpack,
there's no need to limit yourself to salads and juice.
I can't tell you how many times I've had older day hikers look at my backpack
and tell me they wished they had done more backpacking when they were able to.
It's a really unique experience.
Experience out there on your own.
Yeah,
I bet it is.
Well,
what can you please write back and tell me what you do about animals,
man,
because I'm telling you right now,
I'm not doing this.
You know,
the only way I would do this is that I was in a fucking platoon and we all had
machine guns.
Just in case I missed.
Um,
anyways.
Oh,
here he goes.
He's going to calm me down and it isn't nearly as dangerous or as difficult as
people make it out to be.
If you stay on the trail,
you'll usually run across another hiker every few hours.
Oh,
that's comforting.
That's comforting.
Every couple hours I can run into Johnny Appleseed,
but during the other hour and 50 minutes minutes,
I'm on my own.
All right.
Ah,
you're running usually run into another hiker or every few hours that can help
you.
If you get hurt at bears,
mountain lions and all those other bees kill a lot fewer people than Los
Angeles.
Traffic accidents do.
Well,
I used to do a bit on that.
obviously,
because the fucking,
you know that you're running into one person every two hours.
Sir.
Let's do the math here.
Okay?
Okay.
Here's the deal.
There's like 7 million people in Los Angeles.
Yeah.
Okay.
You can't fucking go anywhere without running into like a thousand fucking
people out here.
You're somewhere where you walk every two hours and run into one human being.
So obviously I can guarantee you if those lines and mountain lions were down
here,
the death rate would be through the fucking roof.
Okay.
All right.
This is the guy,
this is what he says too.
He goes,
just keep your food away from your tent and you'll be fine.
Yeah.
Do you understand,
sir,
that you're telling me to do something where if up to near my food supply,
I could possibly get eaten to death.
You want me to leave my living room?
You know,
why can't I just sit on my back porch?
Well,
listen,
I would love,
I,
I would love to too.
Go hiking like that.
I really would,
but I cannot get past.
MMM,
no.
And I don't think you should be able to get past it.
That there's,
that type of shit is out there.
All right.
And if you get mauled to death as a standup comedian,
yeah.
You really would just looking for trouble,
aren't you?
I,
that's,
you know,
somebody just asked me to do a cruise to do standup on a cruise and I,
I told them I wasn't going to do it and they said,
why not?
And I said,
because I'm terrified of the ocean.
Okay?
That's why I don't,
I,
I respected the ocean is not the ocean.
It is the ocean,
but it's,
it's literally
okay.
You're talking about
it's outer space on earth.
That's what it is,
okay?
You can't breathe in it.
You're not.
You can't be in it.
If you're in it too long.
You,
you're either going to get hypothermia or something's going to come up and take
a bite out of yet to see if your edible,
okay
or you're going to drown.
Those are your three fucking options.
And I know what you're thinking,
dude is just safe,
man.
You're out there on this big fucking boat yet.
And until you're not,
until you're not
okay,
and then you proceed to die.
One of the slowest,
most terrifying fucking deaths that there is treading water in the middle of
fucking nowhere and somebody is to die.
No matter how fast they can fucking get you out that somebody is going to die
and people follow.
I fucking,
we did one cruise in my life and I could not,
I couldn't get past the fact that I was on something that the second it fucking
shits the bed.
And I know you guys think that you go,
I've been on cruises and go fuck yourself.
I talked to the band that was on this cruise ship for fucking years and they
told me stories over a little fucking played a Jello late at night.
Those awful cruise desserts.
So poor excuse for fucking,
I also,
I don't like fucking going out there and all of a sudden it's maritime laws and
this Douche bag who didn't even run for office is now telling me what the
[inaudible] it's whatever he says goes with his stupid ass fucking outfit.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
they told me stories.
Yeah.
Okay.
They told me,
they told me enough fucking stories about food poisoning,
about shit back and up about,
uh,
one engine not working and now they're going half speed and then they don't make
it to all the cities.
And then they make up shit about hurricanes and then they have,
fuck it.
Trust me.
People have medical issues and having to be fucking helicoptered off and flown
is quickly,
is human possibly possible.
Not to the best possible hospital to the nearest one.
All right.
And you're going on a cruise.
They go all over the fucking world and they go buy a bunch of fucking countries
that you wouldn't want to fucking get have.
I've have a Goddamn hangnail in,
but all of a sudden they're the closest one.
And that's where the fuck you're going.
Dole.
Hey Doctor Harry,
hack it off.
Fuck that.
All right.
Fucking combined standup comedy in waterworld.
I'm not doing it.
All right.
So that's the thing of it.
I would absolutely love to go backpacking.
I would love to do that.
I would love to go up fucking mountains.
It's way better than going to the gym.
I understand 100% what you're talking about,
but do that shit where you run into a bear mama bear and it,
okay.
Turns around and just runs it.
You 35 40 miles an hour,
you basically,
and you're sitting there hearing this,
this beast
like trees getting out of the fucking way.
It's this thing is just coming,
flying down the fucking hill at you and you're running,
knowing you're going to get caught and you're here and you're stupid.
Pots and pans,
click clank and together and all you're trying to do is just get out in front of
your friend.
So he's the one that goes down.
And so you can live knowing for the rest of your life what your strategy did.
Killed your friends here in his cries.
Boom,
whatever the F,
what is the sound of having your face ripped off?
Okay,
I like to lose weight like the next guy,
Jesus guy.
Go out there with the a beer.
We have fucking bear mace.
Fuck all of that.
Bears.
Mountain lions,
poisonous snakes.
What about if you just,
and then all the fucking varmints out there.
I love that word because you sent him,
he,
Sam's the only person I ever heard use it.
And I,
when I found out it was actually a credible word and not something made up.
I absolutely love that word farm.
It's,
yeah.
You know,
badgers,
wolverines,
bobcat's people look at bobcat's like they no big deal.
If it got scratched by a fucking house cat,
how bad that,
that thing can fuck you up with its little ass.
Fucking pause.
All right.
You want a goddamn links jumping on.
You don't want to fucking town cause it's board.
Oh,
you're freaked out.
Oh you came near to near something that had peed on and you have no fucking
idea.
That's another thing,
dude,
you're,
you're in their world.
This guy actually actually respected the fact that I said I'm not doing it,
but I honestly,
he,
I think he thought it was pretty peculiar that I,
I wouldn't do a stand up on a cruise.
I just jumped subject.
Sorry.
And,
uh,
and I was waiting for him to ask me why and I would just be like,
well,
you know,
would you do a podcast?
Okay.
You know,
and,
and on a,
on a boat in a lake that's full of fucking alligators,
I mean,
you can,
okay,
we're on the boat,
everything's fucking fine,
but it's really,
it's just an unnecessary risk that you take.
Goes all the way back to that fucking saints fan.
He got off easy.
That same fucking guy put that guy with his Jersey with his video cam camera
walking up to a mama bear screaming who day,
who day and all that type of shit.
And he's worried about getting spit on his face.
He would have bare saliva all around his fucking neck.
Oh Jesus Christ.
I've actually thought about that.
Like,
what did I have do if a bear was running right at me?
I just wished that I would have the wherewithal to run right at it.
Like,
you know,
if a shark was coming at me,
swim right at it and it as quickly as you can,
shove your fucking head in there and get it over with.
That is the only fucking strategy.
What are you going to climb a tree?
Things going to go right up that tree.
Did you ever see that youtube video of those guys sitting in the tree hunting
that bear and all of a sudden the bear just literally runs up the tree next to
them
and is like,
like I dunno,
seven feet above them on the tree next to him leaning out,
sniffing at them,
trying to figure out what the fuck they are and I love how the bears just
instinctually,
it's thankfully,
no,
it's just like,
like what?
That bear eight feet above you.
That's like when you're in the upper deck of a stadium,
you know and you shit faced and you get into it with somebody two rows behind
you,
they automatically have the advantage because they're punching down,
right?
You're going to lose that fight.
You're going to fall on your back.
You probably going to break your ankle.
Something's going to get twisted as this guy's punching down at,
you're not.
Just imagine it was a bear.
That was the situation these people are,
and you got to check out that video,
this fucking bear.
It was on the ground and they're whispering in their little fatigues looking at
this thing and then this thing,
I don't know how it found them.
You just heard and that was it.
Over this thing was all of a sudden,
not on the floor of the forest,
20 feet down.
It was now eight feet above them,
sniffing up them like,
Ooh,
is that a food source?
Yeah.
Jesus.
Do you really just hit on like two people today hit on two tremendous fears.
I have been alone in the fucking wilderness and and,
and being out to sea.
Fuck both of those,
although I want to hear the stories.
If you do it,
not if you went on a cruise.
I don't give a shit going out there eating Jello with the date rape drug,
fucking Weirdo,
you know,
to go see the reunion of Wham Cindy Lopper cruise.
Whatever the fuck you doing.
I don't know.
All right.
Advice on college selection.
Oh wait,
let me,
let me read the last couple of fucking ads here.
All right.
All the classic.
Here we go.
Take it to this street,
stamps.com everybody,
one great resolution you can make for this new year.
Maximize every minute and every dollar for your small business.
And you know what?
I know an easy way to do that.
And easy,
simple way.
What is it?
It's stamps.com think about how much time you've wasted going to the post
office.
I get done thinking about it.
Driving,
they're finding parking standard,
but the homeless guy,
old and the door.
You got to fish for a dollar pain in the ass.
Uh,
just use what you already have.
The weight stamps.com is a way to get posted.
It's just use what you already,
you already have your computer and your printer to get official us postage for
any letter or package.
Then the mailman comes by and picks it up with stamps.com everything you would
do with the post office.
You can do it right from your desk.
There's no reason to go to the post office anymore.
You could do it right at your home for a fraction of the cost,
uh,
with a fraction of the cost of one of those expensive postage meters.
I've been using stamps.com for I think two years at this point.
It's so easy,
so convenient,
even a more unlike me.
Configure it out.
So don't wait.
Uh,
right now go,
go to,
uh,
use my last name,
bird to get this special offer.
No risk trial plus $110 bonus.
That includes a digital scale and up to $55 free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com.
Before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in burpee.
You rr that stamps.com.
Enter burr.
All right,
who's next?
Who's next for the butcher?
And he voiced the holidays are coming.
The you still with this,
this copy.
He voice.
Are you serious?
He voiced the holidays are coming.
Everybody there are only 12 months away.
And as a business owner,
you know what that means?
Crickets face it.
The next couple of months or 12 months are are the calm before the storm.
Now's the time to do something that will dramatically help your 2014 he voice
eve voices.
The simple technology that helps you make more money with he voice toll free or
local numbers,
call routing tools and a professional dial by name directory.
Your business will look like a million bucks and with the voice you can't take a
call.
Jesus Christ bill and with he voice.
If you can't take a call these saints,
we'll transcribe the voicemail and email it to you so you'll never be caught off
guard again.
Eva Voice has been saving companies thousands of dollars every month,
making them more efficient and more productive.
There is no quicker or easy way to transfer.
Transform Your Business for 2014 and with the voice you can try it before you
buy it.
Right now,
you can get a free 30 day trial to eve voice.
When you go to eve,
voice.com/ [inaudible] or go to a billboard.com and click on the voice banner.
That's he,
voice.com/bill burr or bill burr.com and click on the voice banner.
Now's the time to take charge of your business and prepare for a productive 2014
go to he voice.com/spielberg go to [inaudible] dot com all right,
that's the deal.
That's it.
That's the advertising for this week.
Okay.
My apologies to anybody who had to listen to me butchered my way through that.
All right.
Advice on college selection.
Uh,
dear billion bourbon.
I'm an 18 year old senior,
headed into my final high school semester and I'm conflicted as to what school I
want to attend after high school.
I've narrowed it down to two colleges.
I wonder what extent each polar opposites.
Jesus.
Dude,
this is like one
of the biggest decisions of your young life and you just heard me trying to read
out loud.
Okay,
so take everything that I say with a grain of salt.
All right.
The first this person is considering is the University University of Arizona.
This safe,
cheap a choice.
We're all,
my buddies are going to go and it's in,
it's in state with about 40,000 enrolled students.
I got to tell you right off the bat,
that sounds fun cause I don't like to read.
I don't like to study.
I like to drink with my friends and I like talking to the lady.
So I'm already liking university Arizona.
Goddamn.
But that sounds like a nightclub to me.
Uh,
they off.
Okay.
They offer my first choice for a major,
what they offer my first choice for a major.
Oh,
they offer my first choice for a major,
which is nutrition and it's a two hour drive from home,
which is nice considering my family is still mourning the loss of my dad at
Jesus.
Dude,
I'm sorry to hear that.
Wow.
All of a sudden that takes all the fun out of this.
Uh,
the downside is that everyone from my high school goes there and I feel like
it's a cop out choice.
I have a good,
Eh,
I know what you mean.
You know,
plus you want to meet all bunch of,
a bunch of new women.
You know,
possibly get some shady pasts.
That's always great to go to a new college.
You just fucking reinvent yourself.
MMM.
Like hipsters tried to do,
they try to act like they were the cool guy in high school that fuck the
cheerleaders,
you know,
as they sit there dress like Robert Fulton for no fucking apparent reason.
Anyways,
I had a good jeep,
a good GPA,
fantastic test scores and enough extra curriculars to get me into some pretty
selective schools.
So I feel like you have a isn't enough of a challenge.
I don't really have much incentive to go there.
Then I fear I'll be unhappy.
I'll be unhappy there due to the lack of risk taking.
All right dude,
you sound like you make,
you're already making the choice.
I feel Eulene um,
you jumping offsides here.
Uh,
the other is Lewis and Clark College.
Ah,
Jesus Christ,
a liberal arts college in a beautiful part of Portland.
Dude,
you just went from blondes in Bikini's to uncontrolled bushes were in Bergen
stocks.
Now I know.
I'm stereotyping.
All right.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
You really are a smart one,
aren't you?
Nah.
You know what?
Okay,
wait a minute,
I'm going to stop being an asshole.
You don't university going to the fucking University of Arizona.
From what I've heard.
That's just like,
remember that guy used to take those creepy videos of the girls gone wild.
You know cause girls got roof feed was a little too
on the nose.
That's what air those Arizona college is sound like.
Um,
I had a buddy of mine from high school.
He went out there and he got all fucked up.
It was,
it was too much.
Girls came to fucking classes and bikini tops.
What are we supposed to do anyways?
He goes,
the other is Lewis and Clark cause at least they did back in the 80s.
The other is Lewis and Clark College.
It's a liberal arts college in a beautiful part of Portland.
Portland,
Oregon is fucking gorgeous with about 2000 kids.
It'd be a nice distance away from home and it's the college where my heart lies.
What do this,
is it right here?
2000 kids is great man.
Going to a school where it's a fucking city,
that they all have their own bus system.
Man,
that's insane.
Uh,
just personally speaking,
he said it'd be a nice distance away from home and it's the college where my
heart lies.
Yeah.
Dude.
And you grew up in Arizona.
Go see something different.
Uh,
the campus is absolutely incredible and we have family up there in case
something goes wrong.
It's a tad more pricey.
But my family set up is my,
sent my family set up to where I have the option to spend a lot on college.
The downside is that it's such a change for me.
A new city.
I have visited it,
but it's far away from home now.
You know,
high school friends and I'm a natural pessimist.
So I wonder what the gloomy grey winters will do to me mentally.
I'll do,
fuck this man,
man up.
You want to go?
You're scared.
You should be scared.
You're 18 but it's good.
This is a good thing to be scared of and to get over.
You got to go out there,
dude.
Jesus Christ.
You live in Arizona.
You can fucking come there anytime you want to fuck that.
Go Away to school,
man.
Portland is this shit.
Oregon's beautiful all the way up into Washington.
It's fucking gorgeous,
man.
Cruise down to Coosbay Bay.
I've been all over that fucking state.
It's awesome.
And not only that,
you know,
they got great college football up there.
Now
if you're in that type of shit,
go to one of those Oregon Games.
I'd fucking do that in a second.
Um,
anyways,
I'll keep going.
He says the Portland weather is almost the polar opposite of Arizona weather and
that spooks me at it.
Don't rain doesn't hurt.
All right,
you'll be fine.
You know.
All right.
Still,
I feel like Lewis and Clark is the opportunity that had been waiting for a plus.
I'm a relative,
relatively solitary person,
so I think I'd fit in with the more mellow campus that a fraternity runs school.
Like you have a,
it sounds like you would,
essentially it comes down to huge party school versus beautiful small liberal
arts school.
Uh,
the thought of being alone with no one I know in a new school scares me and
excites me at the same time.
Let me know.
Thanks in advance.
Go Fuck Yourself,
dude.
Give out.
You've already made your rod decision.
You want to challenge yourself.
It's exciting.
You're going to meet new people.
It's going to be awesome dude.
It's got to be fucking awesome.
Go up there and have a great time.
And uh,
as far as I know,
if there's a party going on,
you basically have a party school.
Okay?
Don't want to,
all you want to do is just fucking party the whole God damn time cause you're
not gonna learn anything.
It's going to go by like that tailgate I went to and you gotta be drunk and
belligerent and act like a fucking moron and come out of there with a big booze
head.
You don't want to do that either.
Um,
believe me,
if you think that people aren't partying in Portland,
first of all,
if I had the guests,
they probably make insane fucking weed in that state.
I don't know if it's legal,
but by the time fucking November rolls around,
it probably will be.
Oh,
Jesus.
I mean,
I would live there.
I would live in Seattle.
I would live in Portland.
I would live in any either,
well,
either one of those states,
more northern Oregon or I would live on the coast.
It's just some of the most lush land you're ever going to see with all of that
rain.
I'm telling you,
it's absolutely fucking gorgeous,
man.
It's fucking gorgeous.
You know when the People Bullis,
Matt,
you know rains all the time.
They got nothing to do was sit around and read.
Um,
all right advice.
Dear Bill.
Fagens.
Oh Jesus.
He went home a phobic.
I am taking an anatomy class before I start the med school shit show.
Oh Jesus.
All right.
There's this hot chick that I've been doing.
This sounds like the beginning of a porno.
You're going to be a doctor in medical school.
You taken an anatomy class.
Here comes this hot chick,
and what she wants you to help her out with the anatomy is you take out your
fucking Dick.
There.
He goes,
says hot chick that I've been talking to,
but I feel creepy about asking,
asking her out while we were digging out
a dead grandmothers Fallopian tube together who was probably a peach
dude.
I'm gonna tell you right now,
you're,
you're in the game.
You are so in the game.
You don't even fucking understand it.
All right?
You're,
you're smart enough to be in medical school.
You've got to be a doctor.
So right there,
you're a fucking rock star to women.
They all,
who doesn't want to bring him?
He's in medical school.
He's got a mom and dad.
I am I dating of fucking guy in medical school.
Not Top of that.
You're fucking hilarious.
That's it.
One,
two punch.
It's over.
Okay.
Upper cut to the fucking snatch over there.
Um,
he said,
how should I approach this?
Okay.
By the way,
when are you going to come to San Francisco with gingerly love?
Um,
let's see here.
How do you approach it?
Well,
do it.
Yeah.
Well,
you don't have to hit on her while you're working.
How about you're in the,
when you were in the lunch room?
I like,
dude,
you're already,
you're so fucking in there.
It's ridiculous.
You're already funniest fucking hell.
So I have total faith in you all.
You all you need is the location,
I would say.
Yeah,
when you're not standing next,
you know,
digging into a cadaver.
Other than that,
you know,
just start working on him,
working on,
you know,
make her laugh at work.
Ask her about her background,
but Baba Ba,
you know?
Yeah,
but don't fucking,
you know,
talk to her too long before asking her out.
Okay?
You don't work the body a little bit.
A,
where'd you grow up?
How many brothers,
sisters,
you got blah,
blah,
blah.
And
you know,
I don't know asking you,
you seen anybody?
Boy,
did you like to fucking see me?
And then you fucking open.
Yeah,
your lab coat with nothing underneath it.
You flasher so you could get away with it.
You're in anatomy class.
Bang.
That's how you do it now.
Um,
dude,
you're going to be fine.
You don't need my fucking help.
All right.
Just don't do it when you're dissecting shit.
Jesus Christ.
Is that guy fucking killing it or what?
Don't you wish you had his life?
He could do it over again.
He was smart enough to get into medical school and there's some hot chicken.
You're fucking class
Jesus.
I can tell you this search.
She's going to be the first of many.
All right,
you motherfucker.
All you gotta do is walk around with that stethoscope around your fucking lab
coat with the scrubs on.
Forget it.
It's going to be raining,
hailing.
Fucking Johnny blue top shelf fucking pussy for you.
Good.
Good on you.
Good on you,
sir.
You study,
you study the Nice School.
You deserve it,
or you fucking a,
you were born with the AA brain.
You got the a brain
ever tell you about that.
My philosophy,
some people get the a brain.
Some people get the be brain.
Some people get to see brain and then after that,
I don't,
I don't make fun of people.
All right?
I Make Fun of the the sea brain.
Okay?
See,
brain is,
is that person that you know,
okay.
You know,
you know those mouth breathing fucking morons,
those people all right.
Yeah.
They got to see brain that one where they can get a driver's license,
you know?
Yeah.
They can pour themselves a bowl of cereal,
but,
and they can get to work on time.
Yeah.
You know those people,
like when you ask them a question,
they get a look on their face,
almost like they're going to start crying.
That would be the sea bright.
The Bee brain
would be,
would be me.
You're smart,
but you're a fucking idiot.
Yeah.
And then the a brain is you just,
you know,
just straight across the board.
You're a number one draft pick.
All right.
I would go late in the third round,
but I got a lot of hot.
All right.
The campaign voice bill,
uh,
we're going to get America back to work and it's time we give tax cuts to people
who,
who really need them.
Had me rolling.
When I first heard you do that stereotypical campaign voice,
you know,
it's funny,
I don't even know what voice said is,
I remember saying that stuff.
I do what?
I don't.
I'm thinking like I don't yell do I don't even fucking know.
I can't remember.
Anyways.
I've heard you do the campaign voice a few times on Conan,
opie and Anthony,
et cetera.
Do you do that in your act or was that just something you did during the
presidential election season?
It must've been because I can't remember how to do it.
I was just fucking killing me.
Do I do it?
My Am I do.
I do.
I have a funny voice and I'm not utilizing that.
Could get me another fucking desperate six minutes to my act.
Uh,
would you do a few minutes of it on your next podcast?
Well,
what am I a fucking jukebox?
Listen,
I'll do it for you,
but you got to send the audio of you doing your impression of it.
All right?
You got to make an ass of yourself and then I'll fucking tap dance for you.
Um,
thanks.
He says,
I've been paying attention to your comedy since I caught your half hour special
when I was in middle school and I'm now 47 off kitty.
Uh,
I'm really happy for all your success and I wish you continued success.
Jesus Christ.
People are coming out of the gate and 2014 really nice.
Thank you very much,
sir.
How do I do that thing?
How did we do the campaign voice?
That's not the one that absolutely purple ball pump pump pump.
They just like,
what was it?
That one.
Now you've got me in my head.
See I'm,
I'm uh,
I'm,
I'm smart but I'm a fucking idiot.
I can't even remember the shit that I do.
Ah,
fuck.
Anyways,
here's the wrap up everybody.
Now that the show is over,
don't forget to sign up for your free trial of Hulu plus who the plus lets you
binge on thousands of hit shows anytime,
anywhere on your TV,
PC,
smartphone,
or tablet.
Support this podcast everybody and get a free trial,
extended free trial of Hulu plus when you go to the podcast page at [inaudible]
dot com and click on the Hulu plus banner or go to Hulu plus.com/bill.
That's Hulu plus.com/.
Bill.
There you go.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast for this week.
And,
um,
once again from the bottom of my heart,
thank you to Randy Bauman for hooking me up with the,
uh,
the Gig.
Thank you to Mario Lemieux and all everybody at the camp,
everybody that I played with,
everybody who laughed at the joke,
so me and Steve Byrne told them,
um,
I don't want to speak for Steve,
but I think I can.
That was a,
we would just shaking our heads today.
Uh,
we flew back,
we connected in Dallas and we got,
uh,
um,
they would d ice in our planes.
We missed the connecting flight and we got stuck there for a couple hours.
Those you follow me on Twitter?
I was twittering my fucking misery when I was there until I saw the guy with the
neck brace sneeze.
That fucking killed me.
The look of panic on his face because he knew he was going to sneeze and he knew
it was going to hurt.
I,
if I could ever,
if I could do that face on cue,
I swear to God I could win a fucking Oscar.
Um,
but anyways,
we were sitting there in the,
uh,
in the airport just talking about
just talking about how
just shaking our head,
it was unbelievable.
But as always,
you know,
I'm not going to name names and all that type of shit.
Um,
but uh,
it was,
it was fucking amazing,
man.
Fucking amazing.
So,
uh,
that's it man.
That's my,
that's how my 2014 started and um,
people actually have pictures of me now wearing Pittsburgh,
penguin,
jersey.
That's the only thing.
But I was willing to pay that price.
Uh,
I got to thank ty Domi for punching off Samson in the face.
It's just how do you fucking beat that?
How,
what,
where does 2014 gold from here?
I'll tell you now that the show's over,
don't forget to sign up for your free trial of Hulu Plus Hulu plus such.
You binge on thousands of hit shows anytime,
anywhere on your TV,
PC,
smartphone,
or tablet.
Support this podcast once again and get an extended free trial of Hulu plus,
when you go to the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com and click on the Hulu
plus banner,
or go to Bill Burr,
or sorry,
or go to Hulu plus.com/bill.
Once again,
that's Hulu plus.com/bill,
thank you for listening.
That's the podcast for this week.
Go Fuck yourself and,
uh,
I'll talk to you next week.